.
ONLY A DISMAL 39% APPROVE OF
BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE IN A NEW
POLL, AND THE MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS WANT THE PARTY TO FLAT
OUT DUMP HIM AND PICK SOMEONE
ELSE AS THEIR 2024 NOMINEE.
THERE'S NO CIRCLING BACK ON
THIS.
REMEMBER THAT?
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SAYS DEMOCRATS ARE
DOOMED IF THE MIDTERMS ARE ABOUT
BIDEN.
>> IF THE ELECTION IS ABOUT
WHO'S THE MOST EXTREME, AS WE
SAW KEVIN McCARTHY TOUCH ON
THERE WITH MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, I'LL SAY HER NAME,
SITTING ON HIS LEFT SIDE, IF
IT'S A REFERENDUM ON THE
PRESIDENT, THEY WILL LOSE, AND
THEY KNOW THAT.
>> AS DEMOCRATS REEL FROM ALL
THE BAD NEWS, THERE'S MORE, A
TOP POLLTER PREDICTS THAT THE
GOP MIDTERM TURNOUT WILL EXCEED
ALL EXPECTATIONS.
>> THIS YEAR OUR FEAR PEOPLE
WON'T BE POLLED THAT ARE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS BECAUSE OF WHAT BIDEN
HAS SAID, APPARENT ATTACKS,
PEOPLE COMING AFTER THEM.
THERE'S A HESITANCY TO
PARTICIPATE.
EVERYBODY WILL UNDEREXPECT THEM.
>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I BET YOU HAVE A BOOK, DON'T
YOU?
HIS NAME IS ROBERT TRAFALGAR.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THE SUBVERGED VOTE, BECAUSE
IT'S RELENTLESS SMEARING OF
TRUMP VOTERS IS PUSHING THEM
FURTHER UNDERGROUND, WHICH MEANS
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE OUTCOME
WILL BE IT, WHICH WAS THE SAME
TO BREXIT, TRUMP, AND PROBABLY
THE ITALIAN PRIME MINISTER.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS?
>> IT COMES DOWN TO THE ISSUES.
WE SEE IT IN EVERY ELECTION.
WHATEVER THE ISSUES ARE MOST
IMPORTANT TO THE COUNTRY, THAT'S
THE PARTY THAT WILL WIN.
RIGHT NOW THE REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING WELL.
YOU SAW THE ABC/"WASHINGTON
POST" POLL THAT SAID ALL THE
ISSUES THAT REPUBLICANS CARE
ABOUT -- THOSE ARE THE TOP FOUR
ISSUES PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
IMMIGRATION IS DOWN THERE.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
REPUBLICANS.
THE THINGS THAT ARE THE ISSUES
FOR DEMOCRATS, THEY HATE TRUMP,
SO JANUARY 8TH.
6th.
THEY LOVE THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ABORTION.
THEY WANT EVERYONE TO HAVE AN
THOSE ARE THE TOP THREE ISSUES.
THOSE ARE NOT AMERICA'S ISSUES.
THE GROCERY STORE, $1.15 FOR A
POUND OF TURKEY.
NOW IT'S $4.
FAMILIES CAN'T AFFORD IT.
THINGS ARE CHANGING.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE CHOICES,
PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE CHOICE, WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BUY AT THE
GROCERY STORE.
YOU WON'T BUY THE MOST EXPENSIVE
APPLE.
YOU'LL BUY THE ONE IN THE BAG
THAT COMES WITH FIVE OR SIX
APPLES.
WE'RE TRYING TO HEAT OUR HOMES.
THEY'RE NOT AS GOOD, BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO HEAT OUR HOMES.
YOU HAVE TOUCHES THAT, THAT'S A
NECESSITY, IF YOU HAVE KIDS.
INFLATION IS GOING UP.
PAYCHECKS ARE STAYING STAGNANT
AND PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD IT.
THAT'S THE MAIN ISSUE.
THAT'S WHY REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO DO WELL.
>> THE MESSAGE I GOT FROM YOU,
THE REAL WINNERS ARE THE
TURKEYS, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> YES, YES, YES.
THERE'S A GOOD POINT, UH, JUDGE,
THAT JEN PSAKI, YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THE REFERENDUM ON --
>> YOU CAN'T ASSUME THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AREN'T INCREDIBLY
SMART IN POLITICS.
I MEAN, LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, JEN PSAKI HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD WHEN SHE TALKED
ABOUT WE HAVE TO GET BIDEN OUT
OF THE PICTURE, BECAUSE WITH ANY
MIDTERM, IT'S ABOUT HIM, NOT THE
PEOPLE LOWER ON THE TICKET.
WE HAVE TO MAKE CRIME AN ISSUE
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
UNBRACING.
IF WE MAKE CRIME AN ISSUE THAT
WE'RE SO GREAT ON, WHICH IS ALL
OF A SUDDEN LAST WEEK THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT A BILL THEY'VE
BEEN FIGHTING ABOUT, HAGGLING
OVER FOR MONTHS, TO MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE WE'RE BEING TOUGH ON CRIME.
I MEAN, THEY'RE SMART.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW LONG OF A
MEMORY DO AMERICANS HAVE?
DO THERM THE SUMMER OF 2020?
DO THERM BUILDINGS FIRE, PEOPLE
DYING, PRECINCTS BURNING, POLICE
FORCED OUT OF THEIR OWN
PRECINCTS.
IF THERM THAT -- LOOK, WE'RE A
COUPLE BLOCKS FROM ST. PAT'S.
WASN'T SOMEBODY SHOT HERE THIS
WEEKEND?
OKAY.
WE'RE AFRAID TO WALK OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING IN NEW YORK CITY.
WHEN IT COMES TO FEAR --
AINSLEY, I KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT,
THE ABC/"WASHINGTON POST" POLL,
THEY PRIORITIZE DIFFERENT
THINGS, AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID OF, I'M AFRAID, AM I
GOING TO BE A COLLATERAL VICTIM,
I THINK THAT WITH PEOPLE DENYING
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN, I THINK IT MAY BE
BIGGER THAN WE THINK.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHO TO GO TO NEXT.
JESSE OR JESSICA?
JESSICA ALWAYS GOES LAST.
I'LL SAVE YOU, JESSE.
>> YOU WANT ME TO TALK NOW?
>> NO.
YOU SHOULD WAIT.
HOW DO YOU KNOW YOU'RE 43 DAYS
UNTIL THE ELECTION, WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS START SOUNDING LIKE
REPUBLICANS.
NOW THEY DISCOVER CRIME AND
CRIME VICTIMS.
RIGHT?
>> IT'S NOT JUST NOW.
THERE HAVE BEEN MODERATE
DEMOCRATS -- DANA IS NOT HERE TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON,
BUT WITH CLYBURN, OUT THERE,
THIRD MOST POWERFUL DEMOCRAT,
SAYING STOP DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, AN ABSOLUTELY ABSURD
IDEA.
THAT STARTED IN THE SUMMER OF
2020.
YOU KNOW THAT THE ELECTION IS
COMING BECAUSE WE HAVE NEW
HIGH-QUALITY POLLS EVERY DAY.
IT'S SO OVERWHELMING, BECAUSE
YOU CAN FIND A NUMBER THAT SUITS
YOUR ARGUMENT, NO MATTER WHO YOU
ARE, RIGHT?
IF YOU THINK IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE YOU CAN FIND
THAT.
OF THE TOP FOUR, YOU'RE CORRECT.
THREE OF THEM FAVOR REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW.
THE ECONOMY, INFLATION, NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER THREE.
EDUCATION, I THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING, DEMOCRATS PLUS SIX
NOW.
DOWN FROM DOUBLE DIGITS, BUT
THAT STILL SHOWS THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT SWAYED
EVERYONE ON THAT.
THE NUMBER FIVE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE ABORTION.
THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THERE'S BEEN HUGE AMOUNTS OF
COVERAGE OF THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
REGISTERING, ESPECIALLY YOUNG
WOMEN.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN KANSAS.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ON OTHER
REFERENDUMS AS WELL.
AND IMMIGRATION AS WELL.
A D PLUS 1 FINDING IN THE
ABC/"WASHINGTON POST" POLL.
THAT SURPRISED ME CONSIDERING
HOW MUCH REPUBLICANS ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE
BORDER.
JOE BIDEN, IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR MONTHS, THEY DON'T HIM TO
RUN.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
DON'T WANT DONALD TRUMP TO RUN.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT PEOPLE
PRIORITIZE, HOW THE PARTICULAR
PARTIES WILL HANDLE THEM IN.
JOE BIDEN IS DOING BETTER AT
THIS POINT THAN CLINTON HAD
DONE, AND THEN TRUMP HAD DONE.
HE'S TWO POINTS BELOW OBAMA.
THERE WAS A POLL, 47% APPROVAL
RATING.
THAT'S PRETTY DAMN GOOD FOR
RIGHT NOW.
>> WAY NOT TO ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
>> WHAT?
I THOUGHT IT ANSWERED IT AND
THEN SOME.
>> YOU DID.
I WAS JOKING.
SO, JESSE, THE REPUBLICANS
DOMINATE ON EVERY ISSUE, BUT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS.
WHAT'S YOUR ADVICE?
WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE?
BECAUSE, JESSICA RAISED SOME
PRETTY GOOD POINTS.
>> I HAVE SOME WHY IS.
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GO LAST, BY THE WAY.
>> BEFORE I GET THERE, I WENT
GROCERY SHOPPING, DO I GET THE
REGULAR OR ORGANIC BLUEBERRIES?
I GOT THE REGULAR, AND THE
BLUEBERRIES TASTED EXACTLY THE
SAME.
>> NO.
>> THEY TASTED EXACTLY THE SAME.
I ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO DO
THAT.
>> YOU'RE LEARNING FROM
INFLATION?
>> I AM, I'M CHANGING MY
SPENDING HABITS JUST BECAUSE OF
THIS INFLATION.
JEN JUST ADMITTED THAT THEY'VE
HAD TWO YEARS WITH FULL CONTROL,
AND THEIR MIDTERM MESSAGE IS
REPUBLICANS ARE EXTREMIST, WHICH
IS A HOAX.
THAT'S CRAZY.
THEY CAN'T RUN ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
THEY DIDN'T BUILD ANYTHING.
WHAT ELSE ARE THEY GOING TO RUN
ON?
COVID RELIEF?
EVERYBODY GOT COVID.
WHAT?
ARE YOU GOING TO RUN ON COVID
RELIEF?
IT TRIGGERED INFLATION.
ARE YOU GOING TO RUN ON THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT?
THAT DOESN'T REDUCE INFLATION AT
ALL.
ARE YOU GOING TO RUN ON THE
BORDER CONTROL?
THE CROSSINGS ARE UP.
THERE'S A LAND WAR IN EUROPE.
YOU CAN'T RUN ON THAT.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO RUN ON?
THE ECONOMY.
STOCK MARKET IS DOWN.
UNDER JOE BIDEN WAGES ARE DOWN.
UNDERIN WE'RE LOSING MONEY.
THE MEDIA COMES OUT, AND YOU'RE
SPINNING POLLS LIKE CRAZY.
OH, HE'S GOT MOMENTUM, THE
DEMOCRATS, YOU KNOW, GOT THE
REPUBLICANS RIGHT WHERE THEY
WANT THEM.
JOE IS LYING, FALLING
DOWN, LOSING US MONEY.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A BIDEN
PRESIDENCY THAT'S A TOTAL FRAUD.
81 MILLION VOTES, HE CAN'T EVEN
DO A RALLY?
THE POOL CAMERA DOESN'T PULL
OUT, BECAUSE NO ONE SHOWED UP.
THE BIDEN RALLY IS FREE.
I TOLD YOU GUYS THE OTHER DAY,
THE WHOLE MOTORCADE CROSS BY
DEEP BLUE MANHATTAN NO ONE
CLAPPED.
IT WAS LIKE THE PRIME MINISTER
OF YUGOSLAVIA.
>> TO BE FAIR, THEY WERE GETTING
MUGGED.
>> THEY WERE GETTING MUGGED.
>> HANDS IN THE HAIR.
"PLEASE DON'T SHOOT ME."
>> SOMEBODY TIED A BANDANNA
AROUND THEIR MOUTH, AND THEY'RE
STICKING THEM UP.
SAME THING WITH KAMALA.
FIRST WOMAN VICE PRESIDENT,
WOMAN OF COLOR, SHE'S A
LAUGHINGSTOCK.
NANCY PELOSI, DEEP BLUE CITY,
GOES BEFORE MILLENNIALS, THERE
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE, AND SHE GETS
BOOED.
DEMOCRATS' MIDTERM MESSAGE
SHOULD BE, I'M SORRY, I'M HERE
FOR THE INSIDER TRADING.
>> WHAT?
>> THAT'S THE TRUE.
IT'S TRUE.
>> WHAT IS THE REPUBLICAN
MESSAGE?
WE'RE NOT THEM?
>> I WOULD SAY WE'RE LOSING
MONEY, CRIME IS UP.
GAS PRICES ARE UP.
INFLATION IS UP.
YOUR MONEY IS DOWN.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
>> AND NO WOME